-And, now, please join me
in welcoming one of the biggest
bands in the world --
BTS!
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
Now!
Alright, you guys, I wanted
to challenge you guys
to a brand-new game.
It is time for Will It Fit?!
-♪ Will it fit? ♪
♪ Tell me, will it fit? ♪
[ Laughter ]
-[ Sings indistinctly ]
-Here's how it works.
I'm going to hit this button,
which will activate
the Will It Fit Generator.
It will give you a random object
on one side
and a different object it has
to fit into on the other side,
such as 42 eggs in a mailbox
or 100 marshmallow Peeps
in a swim cap.
Raise the "YES" paddle,
if you think it will fit;
and raise the "NO" paddle,
if you do not think it will.
BTS, are you ready for this?
-Yeah!
-We're ready.
Let's go.
-Hell, yeah!
Jimin, you're up first.
Your objects are...
[ Shouting ]
-Yeah!
-He says yes!
Alright, here we go.
Let's see if we can get
33 sticks of butter
in a fishbowl.
Whenever you're ready. Go!
-Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
-Will 33 sticks of butter fit
in the fishbowl?
♪♪
[ Cheering ]
Force them to fit.
♪♪
-Oh!
-Suga, be careful.
-Be careful.
-Yes!
He made it fit.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
Next round, J-Hope,
you are up.
-Okay, I'm here.
-Your objects are...
-[ Indistinct ]
Yes!
-Whoo!
-Yeah!
-Let's go!
-Let's go, let's go.
91 is a lot.
91 ping pong balls
in a Christmas stocking.
-Ohh!
-Yeah, that's easy.
♪♪
-Go left.
Go to the left.
-Okay. Okay.
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
Okay.
-Help him out.
-Okay.
-Yep.
-Oh!
-Oh, no!
[ Laughter ]
-There's ping pong balls
all over the place.
There's balls all
over the place.
Get them.
Help him out.
-Last one, last one!
-Last one.
-Yeah!
-Yes, he did it!
91 ping pong balls.
♪♪
This next one is for our RM.
Here's your objects...
-I hate red.
Let's go green!
-[ Laughs ]
So you have to put on
all the shirts
at the same time, is that right?
Or one at a time.
There you go.
Here he goes.
He's going for it.
Ready? Go!
-Go!
-That's one.
-Go, go, go.
-That's one. That's not bad.
That looks like it fits.
♪ Now, will it fit, now? ♪
♪ Tell me, now,
will it fit, now? ♪
-Oh, yeah.
-Come on.
♪♪
[ Clapping ]
-One more!
Got one more!
Can he do it?
♪♪
Look at this guy. That's what
I'm talking about. Look at that!
♪♪
Jungkook, I'd never mess
around with you,
but let's see what this has
to say here.
-Taco shell?
-[ Speaking Korean ]
-I think it's too small,
though, but.
-[ Speaking Korean ]
-Yo.
-Let's go!
-Ah!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Ten scoops into a taco shell.
Do not break the shell.
You have to be very careful.
-Okay, let's go, let's go!
Jungkook, go!
-Let's go, let's go!
-Come on!
-One!
♪♪
-Jungscoop, Onekook!
-Okay.
-Two!
-Two, cool!
-That's two scoops.
-Two.
-[ Speaking Korean ]
-Three!
-Oh, he's mixing the flavors.
Look at this.
-♪ Scoop-scoop, scoop-scoop! ♪
-That's five.
You're halfway there.
-One more.
-It's almost there.
Almost there. Come on.
-Oh, yeah.
-Nine!
-Nine.
-[ Laughs ]
-Last one.
Last, last, last.
-Jungscoop!
-Jungkook!
-J-Scoop!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah!
♪♪
That's how he got the nickname.
Yes!
And he ate some, too.
♪♪
-Suga, here we go,
We got nothing to worry about.
Will it fit?
81 candles on a single cupcake.
Suga says yes!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Tiny cupcake.
Alright, let's go for it.
You ready?
-We don't need the gloves.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Let's go. One.
-Go, go, Suga.
Go, Suga.
-Two.
-You have to be very careful.
You have to be very careful.
This is very precise.
-Four.
-I think it's going
to take a while, baby.
-It's going to take
a little while.
-Ohhh!
-♪ Let's go, let's go ♪
-Let's go.
-Yeah. Let's go.
-Yeah. Finish.
-Let's go, let's go.
-Whoa!
There we go.
Look at that. Come on, now.
And a ping pong ball.
♪♪
V, your objects are...
[ Cheering intensifies ]
How tight are your pants?
-No, he says.
-Yes!
-Now, he says yes!
Are you ready?
-Yeah.
-Set. Go.
-Go. Go on.
-Go, let's go,
let's go, let's go.
-Deep pockets.
-Got big pockets there.
-Ah!
He's got all of them
in one pocket.
♪♪
Yeah, you guys can help him out.
-Yeah!
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
[ Clapping ]
♪♪
That's it right there.
I think I'd say he got it.
♪♪
Jin, you're up next.
Jin, your objects are...
-Fanny pack?
-Oh.
-bananas.
-Yes!
-Yes! Come on!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-He must put on the fanny pack.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Oh, yeah, let's go.
-19 bananas in a fanny pack.
-Okay. Let's go.
-Come on.
Let's go, let's go, let's go!
-Oh, yeah, let's go.
-Let's go.
-Some bananas.
-Bananas.
-Six, seven.
This is unbelievable.
This is not bad.
This is possible.
-Wow!
-He didn't use
the front pocket yet.
-Oh!
Whoa!
-This really crushed.
-Whoa!
I mean, he crushed this one!
♪♪
-It is now time
for the final round.
You all have to vote as a team
for this last one.
Your final objects are...
-[ Laughs ]
-Yes!
I'm 6'0" tall.
-No, come on.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Chanting ] Jimmy!
Jimmy! Jimmy! Jimmy!
Jimmy! Jimmy! Jimmy! Jimmy!
-Oh, alright, here we go.
Alright, alright, alright,
alright, here we go!
-Really?
-Jimmy! Jimmy!
-Let's go!
-Jimmy!
Jimmy! Jimmy! Jimmy!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Wow!
-Oh, my God.
-Whoa!
-Whoa-oa-oa!
♪♪
-Oh, no.
-Really?
♪♪
-Are you okay?
-Oh.
♪♪
-No. The answer is no.
The answer is no, I do not fit
into a washing machine full
of nacho cheese.
♪♪
Alright, my thanks to BTS.
Their single "Butter" is
out now.